now then let's bring you the very latest
on the Press preview we'll first look at
what's on the front pages
on our press preview tonight we'll be
joined by the daily mails consultant
editor Andrew Pierce and the daily
mirrors associate editor Kevin McGuire
um both with us uh well I say both but
you're here on your own at the moment
Kevin we'll get to Andrew up very
shortly
um let's look at the front pages though
first of all the financial times leading
with the latest from Russia the headline
Putin makes nuclear threat as he
mobilizes the Army Reserves for war
the Metro goes with reactions from the
Russian public to Putin's threats the
headline Russians see red at Vlad
The Daily Mail shares prime minister
trust's response to Putin we won't be
cowed by nuclear threats was the UK
leader
trust's reaction is also told by the
telegraph headlining her words desperate
Putin will be defeated the guardian has
President Biden's condemnation as he
calls for a United response
the times also leading with President
Biden's remarks to see Brands Putin's
comments as Reckless
on the cost of living crisis meanwhile
the eye has Liz truss's economic
promises warning the Prime Minister may
be taking a gamble on tax cuts the
health secretary promising all patients
must get a doctor's appointment within
two weeks is on the front of the Daily
Express the mirror leads with the
ongoing search for Olivia Pratt
corbell's killer with a record reward of
200 000 pounds now being offered to help
find the gunman and the star has the
headline
ET thrown home and a call for secret
space documents linked to Prince Philip
to be released to the public
well don't forget by scanning the QR
code you'll see it on screen during the
program you can check out those front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let's go to Andrew and Kevin
there sorry to come to you late
obviously breaking news from the United
Nations General Assembly
um and indeed the situation in Ukraine
and the response from Russia dominating
many of the front pages tonight
including the Ft Kevin no absolutely
we've just heard a very eloquent defiant
speech by uh zielinski there but we
heard a rather rambling deranged speech
earlier in the day from Vladimir Putin
um calling up reservists 300 000 in
Russia is sure sign he's losing we see
the papers are reporting the protests in
cities including Moscow and St
Petersburg is m city against this but
also that uh threat to use nuclear
weapons and he's not bluffing well if
you use a tactical nuclear weapons in
Ukraine that would pose a real issue for
other states but if he fires off in that
Continental ballistic missiles well
nuclear deterrence has failed and I
suspect there would be retaliation and
mass uh mass murder on a huge scale on
all sides but it's very serious but he's
clearly rattled because he is losing
that war he's his aims were to
essentially conquer Ukraine in a matter
of days and uh months later he's now
being pushed back so it's absolutely
serious and it's absolutely dangerous
um but you've gotta you gotta hope that
he actually is bluffing on nuclear
weapons
yes indeed there are so many serious
elements to this the mobilization as you
said that nuclear threat but also um in
the quote from Joe Biden that the Ft
lists there as well
um Andrew
um Joe Biden hitting out at Putin's
overt nuclear threat but he also said
this war is about extinguishing
Ukraine's right to exist as a state
plain and simple that should make your
blood run cold and this breaking all U.N
Charters from a permanent member of the
security Council how can the UN exist as
it does with the flagrant abuses by
somebody who's a permanent member of
that Council
it does it does call it the whole thing
to disrepute really and I mean people
will say they've got to it's better to
have Russia there than not there
um but uh I mean he's a renegade he's a
pirate he's he's faking every rule Under
the Sun the the occupation of Ukraine is
illegal it has been since 2014 there are
war crimes being committed on a daily
basis uh Graves of civilians and
soldiers have been discovered many
people have been tortured uh and um and
it it but I think there's in a funny
sense I think the the rantings and
ravings of Putin today which have
dominated so many front pages is is a
real sign actually that perhaps we're
getting close to the end game Putin is
in trouble I think he knows it
um and the fact that um disturbances
have broken out I think in 38 towns and
cities across Russia uh thousands of
people have been arrested is a positive
sign um of course it needs a lot more
than that to topple him but there is
unanimity amongst this United Nations
security Council America Britain uh
standing shoulder to shoulder I just
wonder about the timing of Putin's uh
Speech knowing that so many uh uh the
big big countries are in the United
Nations today uh and yet and on the same
day we learned that five British uh
Nationals have been released from
Ukraine who have been who were under
Russian captivity what's that about is
that in the spirit of compromise is
there any joined up thinking going on
here or should we not read too much into
it does the right arm know what the left
arm's doing I'm not sure it does yes um
one the inflammatory the other
conciliatory as you say it's fascinating
um The Daily Mail quotes list trust
there are words now coming out about
what she's likely to say at the UN
General Assembly
um in about maybe 45 minutes it's hard
to tell because we saw zielinski going
on rather longer than his allotted time
time but he's she is apparently to tell
world leaders that they cannot be
complacent as free societies face a real
struggle against authoritarianism and it
does really feel like Russia has
completely slipped back to this you know
the it's olden days totalitarian state
does it not as we you know we look at
all of these uh these headlines Kevin
oh oh no absolutely uh it's the Putin
would like to rebuild the you know the
Soviet Union that uh that fell and many
in Russia still consider that a huge
National humiliation which is why when
Gorbachev died he seen as a Great Hero
across much of Europe there was no State
funeral in in Russia and many people did
not mourn him but the the whole question
around the security Council and
permanent members and zelenski picked it
up wino India wino Brazil because it was
really created after the second world
war and there's those five permanent
members on the security uh Council the
U.S Russia Britain France and and and
China it's kind of out of date really
and I I'm with Biden and his criticism
of Russia on an unprovoked uh invasion
of Ukraine but you know U.S foreign
policy uh across much of Central America
South America parts of Africa
Afghanistan and under under Iraq and
Vietnam has been really interventionist
in the past and has killed many many
people and never respected the
sovereignty of states and uh in the UK I
don't think we've got Clean Hands either
over Iraq or Afghanistan or Libya where
our interventions uh cost uh many many
lives we've got we've got one minute
left I just want to get to another story
very quickly Andrew the eye uh warning
over trusses gamble on tax cuts just
very quickly on that if you can well
this is the institute for fiscal studies
saying if her if her pitch that um by
cutting taxes um overturning the
corporation tax rise reversing their
National Insurance right if it doesn't
stimulate the growth that she says it
will that it could cause a real debt
problem and a potential run on the pound
Now The Institute of fiscal studies is
very respected they're just making a
prediction saying potentially if if it
doesn't work but that's the plan she's
decided on it's clear blue water between
the tour series and labor she thinks
whether it's a yeah I've got more better
news apologies very quickly and 215
Ukrainian prisoners uh have been
released from Russian captivity in
another prisoner swap this is in
exchange for 55 Russians and uh Victor
medvedchuk which is a loyal Ally of
Putin we've been waiting for that one we
will talk more